okay well if if you're like me your
attention span is about one minute at
this point so this kind the talk i'm
giving hopefully will not text that so
most of everything i will say will be in
one minute snippets and okay so first it
this is what i'm talking about is joint
work with justin gilmer who is a student
of mine recently finished and we help
good ski and so here's the outline of
the talk i'm going to tell you a game
and a conjecture tell you why it's
interesting I'll say something about why
you might believe the conjecture and
then I'll say something about why you
shouldn't believe the conjecture and
then after this you remember that's
right so why you should doubt it okay
but then at the end I'll say something
about why despite the fact you should
doubt it it still might be true um okay
so what's the game so here's Alice Bob
and so alice is going to get his input a
random permutation which you will think
of as just a sequence of numbers from 1
10 4 1 to n so Sigma 1 through Sigma N
and also a bit II and 0 1 and alice is
going to get these this is going to be
streamed she's going to get Sigma 1
Sigma 2 up to Sigma and then she'll get
B and she'll send a message to Bob and
the message will be constrained in a way
that I'll describe in a minute well this
is going to prepare a message send the
message to Bob and the message will be a
vector which I'll call gamma 0 1 to the
N
and Bob will look at the message and Bob
has to output so Bob looks at the
message and outputs a subset of one
through it
and the requirement of the output is
that Sigma and the very last element of
the permutation should be a member of
the set and the and the cost sighs the
set it but I saw the one thing I haven't
told you is what's what's gamma so what
is what's Alice allowed to send about so
gamma you should think of as inner well
to an array index by 1 through n and it
starts empty now I said that Alice
receives this permutation stream and
Sigma one arrives and think of Sigma 1
as an index into the array and Alice she
can write a 0 or 1 in that position at
that point and then Sigma 2 arrives
and she can write 0 or 1 there keep
doing this
no but there's one catch when sigma n
arrives Alice doesn't get to choose what
to write their when Sigma and arrives
she must write the Big B which is thus
last bit that sent and the stream has to
get written there that's the game ok
this is
my daughters would say if that's a game
remind me not to come to a
mathematicians party um okay but this is
the game and that's the cost and the
value of the game well you know so Alice
has a strategy and you know Alice and
Bob have a strategy and you look at the
worst case costs so once you fix once
Alice fixes a strategy which is how
she's going to respond to each arriving
Sigma I um then the cost is the worst
case / j you think of Sigma B being
Santa anniversary who knows the Uno's
the strategy so um
so we're right vien or the first case
cost of this strategy just to make sure
both avocent over the toys but
everything's everything's deterministic
at least at the moment I like this to
check and send the frozen so you can
solve it on average would log in cause
or what is well make sense to just write
down the value of Sigma n but you don't
know Sigma n 0 Sigma 1 through Sigma
note so this is import this is this is
important right so let's yeah let's now
that I said it let me review the
important part sigma 1 through sigma n b
is arriving as a stream so you get Sigma
1 and you must commit yourself to what
you write in in position Sigma 1 then
you get Sigma 2 and you must commit
yourself to what you're right in Sigma 2
so if it weren't for this big be I mean
here's a strategy you write zero every
time in your right one at the end okay
and then Bob knows what the bid is you
look time and then half the time yeah
but it's worse case that's where's case
its worst case oh that's worst case yeah
that's right but yeah if um all right um
so now here's the conjecture
well I'll say you know some people use
the word conjecture to mean something
they really believe and other people use
it to mean something that and then we've
I've had debates about this with what
should conduct your mean but well to me
it means an interesting question that
would be nice if it's true but I don't
necessarily believe it the conjecture is
that via that there exists a delta
greater than 0 such that the n is at
least into the Delta that's what's it
very distant okay so let's see so that's
the game that's the conjecture I
consider it so can you give us an
example of a strategy I will uh in
number three
so there's an old conjecture in boolean
function complexity called the
sensitivity conjecture which has well
it's interesting it appears in the paper
of Nissan and SEGA t from the early 90s
remember these much here but they don't
stated as a conjecture they stated as a
problem and it became known as a
sensitivity conjecture there's a really
nice survey article about you know a
whole bunch of different reformulations
of it that's it's called variations on
the sensitivity conjecture was which was
written by a group of graduate students
at University of Chicago and I should
have their names but I don't have them
but here's the here's one version which
is
favorite so let F F is a boolean
function or boolean function f so the
sensitivity of F at X here's X and 0 1
is just equal to the number of neighbors
Y of X and these are just neighbors in
the boolean cube such that F of Y is
different than f of X so the number of
bits that you could flip which would
change the value and then the
sensitivity of the function is just the
maximum sensitivity
maximum over all inputs so for example
the end function which is one at one
point and zero everywhere has
sensitivity zero almost everywhere but
there's one point where it has
sensitivity ends so the sensitivity is
and and
there's a talk at 5pm angkat garg here's
the title I'm about to a reason room was
no offense at kick
and then the degree of F is just the
minimum degree well the Fourier degree
or their hell of a real of a real
polynomial degrees with F
so it's known that
sensitivity of X is the most degree of x
cute maybe squared I don't quite
remember me the [ __ ] Nick Oh s-sorry the
argument is f naught X degree of F the
sensitivity is bounded above by some
polynomial in the degree I don't really
care what the number is there and the
conjecture is this a k such that degree
of f is always bounded by sensitivity to
the K let's say
for all functions but for all boolean
functions
Oh
and so now here's a here's a proposition
which says that um
if there exists boolean function of
degree n and sensitivity s and VN the
value of this game is it mostest so if
you had a boolean function where the
sensitivity was really small you could
use it essentially that function can be
used to give a strategy for Alice and
Bob which has very low oh and in
particular so if you could prove that
the game has high cost and you get as a
consequence so it implies a sensitivity
conjecture no yeah I want to mention so
when I publish when I posted the
abstract of this talk I he got an email
from from handy who said I didn't say
what the game was and he described this
game that he'd been thinking about for a
year which turns out to be the same game
and so and he has you know essentially
the same proposition so yeah so that's
what I mentioned it's an independent
discovery of the same question but any
trucker
okay so good is this related to the
Cosmo gringo something um I don't think
so so you know I've got not that much
time so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
prove much the proof of that takes three
minutes four minutes that's more than
the one minute that I promised the year
attention span required okay so I
believe it why should you believe the
conjecture um well 11 is a hopeful
reason like boy well the conjecture is
true it implies the sensitivity
conjecture so that's one reason to
believe it but so well let's think about
you know what what would be a good
protocol how good a protocol can you get
so let's so I'd made a switch to the
sensitivity conjecture now switching
back to the game forget the sensitivity
conjecture let's remember the game
what's the game the game is Alice is
getting streamed the permutation Sigma 1
through Sigma N and a bit be she gets to
write in a vector but the positions
she's she writes in as in the order
governed by the arrival of the preview
tation but she doesn't control the last
bit the last bit is controlled by the be
that comes in all right so ok here's a
here's a slightly non-trivial protocol
you write 0 in the for the first n over
two time steps 0 and then you're right
one for the last n over 2 but you don't
control the very last one but now Bob
looks and he says how many zeros are
there in the vector he sees that there's
n over 2 plus 1 zeroes he know the last
bit that was written was a zero and he
can output the set of zeroes which is a
set of size n over 2 plus 1 and if
otherwise he outputs the set of 1 which
is a set of n over 2 so there's a
protocol which gets on over to how about
how about a better protocol ok so um
take the bits I mean your vector and
break it up into chunks of size square
root end now alice's protocol will be
when Sigma I arrives if sigma i is not
the last thing to arrive in its block
then right 0 and if it is the last thing
to arrive in its block then right one so
you know 2000 and then
my last thing I don't mean last here I
mean the last arrival in the block okay
now what does Bob see well Bob is either
going to see one block that's all zeros
that's if the last bit written is zero
and he knows that the last thing is in
that block so we outputs that block
otherwise he sees one one in every block
which case he opens so there's there's a
protocol of sites so that shows that V n
is less than squirted okay um so we know
this I'm not sure we can do better than
that but it's not so easy to do better
than we're done I don't know anything
better than this so that's one reason to
maybe to believe it is that nobody knows
and you know by now that we've talked
about I've talked about this a few
places people have thought about it and
nobody's beating this is the lower
sensitivity that we know off for a
boolean function again what are the
lower sensitivity that we know of for
any boolean function of only be for sale
yeah so we know a quadratic gap between
senses so this one oh so if you did
there is a [ __ ] this thing actually
comes from a boolean function if you
take the tribes function then that's a
function of degree n and sensitivity
square root n and if you apply the proof
there to this thing which says that give
if you give me up yeah and if you just
apply the proof which I didn't show you
then you will get this game I mean
you'll get this strategy ok um say it
again that you have it's just is there a
function underlying it
no no and that's the you know so we
don't know that things go the other way
it could be the most uninteresting thing
could happen is that the conjecture
turns out to be false but it doesn't
give a counterexample to the sensitivity
conjecture and if if i were to bed on
what's true maybe that's what i think is
going to happen but ok so fine the other
reason why you should why should you
believe it so you know here's an
information-theoretic intuition about
what's happening in this game when i
write the keith bit i'm trying to you
know Alice writes the Cape decayed get
Sigma K writes a gate but so she's
trying to convey some meaningful
information about what's the last thing
that's going to arrive but at that point
all she knows is that it's one of n
minus K things so you know what she
writes can't be very informative about
that you know and if you sort of follow
that reasoning and you think about
information theoretically you can sort
of get some estimate how many bits can
Alice tell Bob about and you get
something like 1 plus you get something
like harmonics on its ass natural log of
n this is very heuristic natural log of
n but she needs to convey log base two
of n bits so there's a gap and that
should reflect and that was so that so
those are the reasons to believe it now
why should you doubt it let me let me
tell you three conjectures three
strengthening
so first strengthening one is consider
Sigma can be uniformly random now
instead of looking at where's case you
look at the average case so you look at
that you look at a strategy and now you
just charge the strategy what's the
average and if you like the strategy i
gave the particular strategy we gave
which was rooted well it's always rooted
so the average case is exactly the same
as the worst case because everyone is
rooted we had the strategy where if you
write 0 every time then with probability
a half you win you only cost you one and
with probability a half it costs you n
so that'll have average case n over 2 so
if I write V Bar in so you know we can
have another conjecture inject your
prime that V Pape so that's a conductor
now here's another if you think about
that and if you think about the
information theoretic intuition then you
can forget about what Bob outputs and
you can just say well what does Bob
learn so what I would like to look at is
what is the residual entropy of sigma n
given the vector gamma how much entropy
is left if in this now we're still in
the random setting so you fix your
strategy you you know Alice follows it
Bob looks at gamma the distribution on
Sigma and B and the known strategy for
Alice induces a distribution on this and
you can just look at what's this and so
it's reasonable
dr. double prime and Andy also
conjectured this one though to
conjecture that this is greater than
some epsilon logon for some cuz I'm
papasan of epsilon so so now and it's
easy to see that this conjecture implies
this one and third conjecture well if
you think about the intuition you could
play the same game except you allow
Alice instead of writing a single bit
she writes to its eid each step same
question right so you or you just say
that the alphabet elf Alice's alphabet
size
um let's say one up to k where k think
of K is a constant you could ask you
know what what happens here give you
zero on order and be all sort of the
same output B is B is in the same
alphabet
ok so now bad news is well this is false
this is false I false I mean so when the
out so here I'll say let's say just stay
with the worst case one and here so if
that is to say there is a there is a
three isn't estate bro ok so then define
VN Super K which means the value of the
game the worst case value of the game
when the alphabet size is K and then you
might say that this should be at least
into the Delta right so what we know the
show it turns out V and three sorry Mike
forever this is going to ensure that
it's both know you wanted so it's free
Delta can depend on k I mean in the
conjecture but it's false so vien vien
three turns out is order log in there is
a conjecture is a protocol if you allow
them in alphabet of size three in which
the the size of Bob's output set is only
order log n okay and this one's false
there is a protocol this is back in the
binary thing in which this is less than
epsilon
some constant C log Lakhan this is what
the uniform is through the uniform
distribution okay and this one we don't
know this is open so in other words it's
very natural to pass to entropy because
we know how to work through proof things
about entropy but this is strong this is
you know though there is a protocol for
this but the protocol that has low
entropy turns out not to have low
expected cost in fact the expected cause
yeah so the expected cost of the
protocol is n over log and are in over
and speak okay but the entropy is small
okay and now my time is up i evoke but
I'm going to take one more minute and
say why so after you hear this you know
the intuition was information theoretic
but the information theoretic statement
is false and the also the intuition
doesn't well you know the same intuition
would say that if you could write three
symbols how does that help that's also
false okay if you look at the protocols
that provide counter-examples to this
they satisfy the following property
which is this that in in the protocols
to specify a probe what Alice does so
you know Alice has filled in some bits
somewhere and then I arrives Sigma I you
know this position let's call it
position J arrives she and her strategy
says well I look at these and I decide
and maybe I also look at the past and I
just decide what to write here and we'll
call the protocol monotone if it says if
it has the property that if you're in a
configuration where if J arrives now
shall write one then later on if some
other stuff arrives and now j arrives
she'll still write one so once she
decides to write one in a location if it
arrives she never changes her mind so
that's a monotone protocol and the
protocols that provide counter examples
for both of these are monotone however
the original conjecture we can prove is
true for monotone so you know I don't
know what to make of that it just is so
in fact and we can prove it with square
root of n in the case of monotone
protocols exactly square root of n the
point nine nine square root of n that is
non monotone alright so that's what I
have to say
so you did add six you say that when you
go from monotone on monotone you go from
sqrt n 2.99 90 there is a number yeah
yeah that's right and I say something
about how the problem yep I'll say I can
say so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to you suppose you gave me this boolean
function so first of all it's easy to
see if you have a function of degree n
you can fix all but end of the variables
and it'll still be degree in so you can
assume your function actually has
exactly n variables and it's 48 degrees
n and it's got sense of the sensitivity
only goes down if you fix variables so
it's still sensitivity us so you start
from this function and now I'll use
another fact which is if you have a
function of degree n and you pick a
variable then there's a way of fixing
that variable so that the degree of the
result the residual function goes down
by exactly one right when you fix a
variable maybe it goes way down but one
of one way or the other of fixing it
only goes down by one so now you take
the function and your analysis strategy
is this she keeps this function in mind
when a variable arrived she sets the
variable in such a way that the degree
of the function when you fixed that
variable goes done by one she keeps
doing that and then you just convince
yourself that at the end and then what
is Bob output Bob at the end receives an
input and he outputs the set of
coordinates on which the function is
sensitive it decides at most s and you
just you know then it's you can just
check that that protocol works